hey everyone I'm Lucy and joining me
today is loose turret from Toys for Bob
to talk about a brand new crash
bandicoot game Lou thank you so much for
joining me
yeah I'm thrilled to be here and finally
get to chat about crash bandicoot for I
know it's a wild they even say that
because crash bandicoot 3 warped was 98
so that game can drink legally now which
is good and now we're getting another
and a brand-new and numbered entry in
this series
so what does it feel like working at
Toys Bob not revisiting this franchises
obviously you guys have worked on it
before but what is it you know putting a
numbered stamp on that franchise I mean
honestly it goes to the original intent
with what we want to do with this game
which is you know we fell in love with
those original games you know back in
drinking age over 20 years ago and for
us it's it's a wholly unique game like
there's never been a platformer that's
felt like a crash bandicoot game and so
for us the main idea with crash
bandicoot 4 was to go back to what made
those games special and to bring that to
a modern era so they you know play like
the original games continue the story
from those original games but the same
time we're adding our own modern spin to
it and so we're just super thrilled as
fans of the the franchise to be able to
kind of add to its storied history
and speaking of story it does pick up
pretty much where 3 left off in terms of
the cannon so where do we find ourselves
as startup cash money good for the
starter Crash Bandicoot for a number of
years have passed since at the end of
Crash Bandicoot 3 entropy neocortex and
hookah hookah had been banished kind of
to the the end of time and space and so
they have been spending all of this time
trying to find a way to break out our
game starts where those enemies those
villains have actually figured a way to
break free from their prison and in
doing so kind of leaves a villain sized
hole in time and space and so it leaves
crash and Coco on the pursuit of finding
the four quantum masks in an effort to
aid them in kind of stopping all of this
calamity and kind of
in time and space what are these quantum
masks do is it similar to you know the
abilities that you gain crash bandicoot
3 or is it something you completely so
it's it's something brand new and it's
something really cool on that you're
gonna be meeting these characters along
this adventure and once they kind of
join your team
there will be areas in the levels where
they'll come in and help you so similar
to how och you be placed in a level
these masks is for quantum masks will
show up an aid in the gameplay and we're
talking about two of them today and they
put a really new spin on the the
platforming questions and the things
that you're gonna be doing is crash or
cocoa and that they actually equip as a
suit and then you have the two we're
talking about our kupuna law who is the
time mask and then ek Iike who is the
gravity mask and so if you get either
them they equip as a suit on your
character and then you have control over
their reality bending powers and so that
means as the if you're wearing computer
wah she can slow down time and so you'll
be doing all this crazy platform
encountering all these crazy challenges
where you need to actually utilize the
power of time to slow it down so you can
actually imagine a situation where
you're encountering nitro boxes which
are you know a classic crash you know
hazard but if you time slow you actually
have the amount of time to hop on them
before they explode and then iko iko
allows you to switch your center of
gravity allows you to completely flip
your characters gravity so you can be in
the middle of a sequence press the
button and boom now you're on the
ceiling and so then you're running on
the ceiling and some crazy scenario
where you're actually platforming upside
down and I noticed you've been saying
crash and Coco so playing as both the
entire game you can choose to play as
either crash or Coco both of them are
actually present in the story so in
every cutscene it's like they're
traveling together we wanted to make
sure that they're there equal measure
through the story but they're not
actually the only playable character so
we're we're hinting a bit at some
additional playable characters through
the adventure can't say too much but you
know playing as neocortex getting a
whole new perspective on everything
would be a lot of fun except for maybe
you know Crash Team Racing well crash
but I never really think of
cortex is a playable character just
think of him as the nefarious bad guy
I'm speaking of nefarious bad guys I
assume big over-the-top boss battles
yeah we're going really big I mean I
always look back at the original games
and you know while they were super fun
boss fights they're actually pretty
small you know I remember the first boss
fight in Crash Bandicoot was against a
man in a house you know and so we're
taking that and we're blowing it up
we're going really big and so some of
the things that you know we've got is
we've got some fan favorite characters
and enemies returning and so one of the
folks were talking on today is engine is
is returning and then in this game he's
got a giant enormous mech and so it's
kind of the toys for mob spin we want to
take you know what was fun about these
original games and just make them larger
and make them more imposing and just
make it really exciting for the player
thinking back to when I was playing it
as a kid when I played it on Vito and I
played this sort of remake from a few
years ago it's like those games are way
tougher and I seem to remember at a time
I like to think that maybe as a child I
was a real pro gamer and maybe I've just
lost that how do you kind of balance
that difficulty when making a platformer
I mean honestly that's one of the things
that we think is kind of part of that
core DNA of Crash Bandicoot it's that
it's asking you this really tensed
precision execution question as a player
but for us as a team we want to make
sure that the game is accessible so
we're kind of looking at ways to expand
in both directions so one of the things
that we're talking about is the fact
that we're actually introducing what we
call modern or retro modes when you
choose to play the game and these modes
actually dictate how kind of death
behaves in the game so if you choose
modern what you'll be doing is if you
die you're going to restart from the
checkpoint every time you'll restart
from the checkpoint you can kind of keep
taking on that challenge and seeing if
you can make it through but if you
choose retro you have lives if you die
you know more than them or lives you
have we're going to toss you a game over
you're gonna have to start from the
beginning but what that does is it
actually changes how we treat wampa
because in the original game the 1po
would give you lives so we're doing that
for retro mode but for modern mode what
we're doing is we're actually tying that
into kind of the call
election and end-of-level rewards so
we're actually giving you an extra ask
of trying to collect these wampa to get
rewards so is it gonna be a set amount
per level now yeah so what we're doing
is we're actually kind of doing both in
a fun way so in retro mode it will
actually continue to have that 100 gives
you actual life but across both of them
for the collection mechanic there is a
fixed amount so the way that it kind of
works is that if you die that grind of
your extra life is still there
but you're still collecting a fixed
number of whump along the way so I think
once you get your hands on it you'll
you'll be able to say gotcha and how do
you kind of balance making a game that
is gonna appeal to you know the people
who grew up with crash bandicoot but
also modernizing it for Iran you
audience yeah I mean honestly it's it's
things like this modern retro it's
quality of life improvements you know
it's it's making it so that way you have
some right right stick camera control
while you're going through your
adventure we're still making it super
accessible and being true the original
games by having say you know a game
authored camera so that way you're
changing those fun perspectives and feel
like a crash bandicoot game but we're
adding additional things we're also
adding platforming tricks to crash and
Coco's move set so the ability to wall
run rope swing rail grind so just a
number of different things that just
make him feel him or her feel really
great to play is bull riding and all
that in from the beginning are they
unlockable as you get through the
campaign they're in from the beginning
it depends on the levels themselves you
know so obviously if there's a rope to
swing on you can swing on the roof how
long has it been in development now I
mean it's been a while I mean I got I
don't know the specific date but for us
it's it's one of those things where
we've been working hard on it for a
while now and seeing the response from
fans to you know the the insane trilogy
to CTR to seeing that kind of fan outcry
of just wanting to play these original
games and wanting to play in that
original style kind of put the wind in
our sails to know that what we're doing
is kind of the right call and making a
game that feels
like these original games but is a true
from the ground up sequel you know
completely new engine to a new art style
completely new adventure and it's
something that we're just incredibly
thrilled to be bringing to the fans
crash has such an iconic look that you
know everyone knows what's it like
putting a new spin on that spin on it
[Music]
the dad jokes are strong with this
franchise now obviously it's been a
complete dream come true for the studio
we have just you know aether they're
fans of the franchise but they're also
fans of what the original franchise was
actually trying to build upon which is
this kind of real great history of
animation and so it's been a real fun
thing for our studio to push on
animation techniques to look at the old
you know animated cartoons that crash
and you know those original games were
we're referencing and so to push the
techniques to push you know the emotive
animation and and fluidity of kind of
the character models or students doing
and then for the levels themselves it's
been really cool because while we're you
know embracing of this original kind of
more old-school kind of flow through the
levels we're actually expanding the
vistas we're expanding the scope of
these levels we're expanding the feeling
of these levels in ways that you know
the original games cousins so we're
taking you to different times and
different dimensions that just look
stunning and we can't wait to show more
just thinking back to some of those
classic levels that like obviously I'm
gonna get the name wrong but the moments
of the boulders wild hog hog wild roll
or all those yeah so a we can I kind of
seeing sort of facets of those levels in
crash 4 or like oh ma jizz great waters
there is a lot of history
the crash bandicoot franchise and you
know we are huge fans of it so I can't
give too many details away but at the
same time you know we want to make sure
that it feels like a crash game well a
huge thing it'll make it feel like a
crash game is the music too I mean we
also that the music's been a huge thing
and actually one of the I wanna say the
foundations of our studio but we have a
real huge musical background in our
studio some of our key studio leadership
originally came from kind of the the
music background and so musicality is
something that's super important to the
team and so we've got a brand new you
know fully composed soundtrack that
we'll be talking about more later in the
future and also just our great musical
influence through the game that I think
will be really apparent when you see it
I'm genuinely so excited it makes it
like crash is one of those franchises
that makes you feel like a kid again and
I suppose the sort of the generation
that grew up with crash they're now
having their own kids and like passing
the franchise down dude did it kind of
feel like a passing of the torch between
you know the studios that like Naughty
Dog you've held the franchise before and
now it's it's kind of toys for Bob's you
know I don't know necessarily a like a
passing a torch to us it felt more like
getting to play in a sandbox that we've
always loved you know it's so getting to
be the the nerdy fans who are now kind
of sculpting the future of something
that we know and love and just are super
passionate about and so you know I keep
jokingly it's like I get to go to work
and make a platformer that is just pure
fun and it's like I couldn't be happier
to be working on this and I think it's
it's the same way with the rest of the
studio toys for Bob we just this is the
type of game that we love to play and so
getting to be able to make that and put
all of kind of the the hopes and wants
and dreams for this franchise that we've
had as fans into it has just been just a
dream come true
fantastic when can we hear more soon I
hope we have lots and lots of stuff to
show and I think everyone's been really
excited to see it great Lew thank you so
much for more on crash bandicoot 4 make
sure you stay tuned to game spot of
course and for all the big summer
announcements we have played for all
running for the whole time all the
biggest new games make sure you keep a
game spot
[Music]